from the makers of power drill massacre
comes murder house
the place where you're gonna get
murdered dead
ooh prologue murder house prologue
murder house prologue
prologue
i always like these types of games
they're so
so so set in a style and i love a style
i absolutely adore a style styles are
fantastic
styles are the best
styles are dope as hell
dope as hell
okay kid you're next i'm next is this me
oh
i'm next
oh god i am next hello
hi kid get your ass up there okay
oh
[Music]
smile kid
[Music]
wow
what a lovely easter
ah
thank you
for that oh hi
hello
hi
i must have fallen asleep where
am i still in the lap of the bunny
uh okay
oh
oh good
ah mom
i always is the mall closed i always
loved how their camera control styles
were always janky
very resident evil ooh this one's fun
though
okay this one's kind of cool very weird
but kind of cool where am i
am i in some kind of a chuck e cheese
am i in a chuck e
cheese oh
oh i'm in a mall
oh wow
i am in a mall
hey
oh
weird
okay
okay
i don't know where my mom is
i don't
know where i am
can someone help me this is like exactly
how i got lost to kings island when i
was like six years old
uh i just got stuck looking at a ferris
wheel that was all lit up and very
pretty and i just couldn't look away and
i the next thing i knew my mom was gone
and i was lost in a sea of people and it
was very scary
and then i don't really remember what
happened next but i do remember
going to like some kind of a security
booth for lost kids because apparently
that was more common than you'd think
of course all that could have been a
fever dream but i'm pretty sure that was
real
you never know at this point i do wonder
if there's like some really really old
archival security footage like some
tapes of kings island way way way back
in the day
that they somehow keep and i'm somehow
there
that'd be pretty crazy don't know where
i made a full circle wait how did i make
one big ass circle and not get anywhere
wait a minute where am i supposed to go
charles entertainment cheese you get
your ass out here and you tell me what
i'm doing
[Music]
what does e do oh i can first person if
i go e
oh
justin justin is my name
so i've pretty much been around this
whole mall and i still don't know what
i'm doing
mom
mom
you know this game's called murder house
and i'm neither in a house nor am i
being murdered
security gate looks like oh i tried to
crawl i tried to crawl under it i tried
i tried okay anyway
now that nobody ever knows about it no
no one know knew what i did there about
how i got lost right lixian that made
sense you understand my words
you understand me don't you good that's
where the easter bunny was taking photos
it sure is empty now
it sure is kid
it sure is let's go in line
yeah okay
easter bunny easter bunny these for
bunny's share i guess he went home for
the night
yeah i guess i don't like the hissing in
the background i don't like the rising
choir of the damned
oh i don't like that
is that just gonna keep happening
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is that footsteps
am i hearing footy steps
oh
this one is locked
[Music]
i don't like it i don't like it i hate
it i hate it i hate it i hate it
i hate it
i can't see
what is that
hello will i take the key yes of course
i'll take the key
of course
i can use inventory items by pressing z
okay
it's locked i can't get out that way
what if i use this
okay what if i use it on the other
security gate though
there's just something about this style
there's just something about the style
of these games same with the person that
made like discover my body and is
currently making discover our bodies
among other things
oh and much like the mystery flesh pit
which i love it's all just very surreal
cosmic horror it's part of the reason
why i like scp so much but only like
particular scps really build on the
entire world of it
a lot of scp is trying to be one scary
thing which is fine that's the whole
purpose of it
but collectively you know
it's all one big thing that's too big to
comprehend and do terrifying to really
comprehend comprehension comprehend
yeah
it's really cool i don't know there's
just something about it
not many people are sticking to this
kind of style or
really like expanding upon it and i love
that
but also if you guys don't know about
the mystery flesh but you you're
probably gonna want to know about that
it's very cool and very horrifying and
what am i looking at what am i seeing i
can't tell what i'm seeing it's so dark
it's like so dark
okay
there's got to be a way out
yeah i'm looking for it
i am looking for hello
hi
door
exit
exit
i don't trust it
i don't trust
oh don't trust it what am i looking at
missing huh missing persons read it yes
daniel gray
interesting
randy martinez
right good
i mean not good but okay
it's locked
authorized person okay i don't like this
i don't like this back room's ass
hallway
[Music]
it's the hallway from terminator 2 when
the terminator walks down and pulls the
shotgun out
oh i don't like that oh good i didn't
actually want to go in the bathroom
because the bathroom horror movie is a
bad thing
it's oh what did i just see i saw the
tippy top of something there oh no
i think i saw the tippy top of someone's
head there
should i hide no why would you hide
no why would you hide in there
why would you hide
seems like a good hiding place i could
peek out with the action button
get a closer look with the look button
when i'm finished hiding i could exit
with menu
i'm sorry what
[Music]
okay
okay
okay i'm not going to try every one of
these because i'm i i don't want to know
what is in every one of these
okay i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go i'm i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
god you know playstation one must have
really burned it it burned itself into
the developers of these games
memories forever or developer or one
person i don't know i mean it's great
super iconic but
man i never really lived the playstation
1 era
i had super nintendo and that was it for
a long time
oh hi
oh hi
oh hi
oh hi yup
uh-huh yep
ah
okay okay i guess it's so captured by
trying to pay attention to which one i
was looking at okay i'm gonna hide i'm
gonna hide i'm gonna hide i'm gonna hide
in this one yep hide
okay now i gotta remember what button it
was he's locked the door there's no
escape
oh boy
oh boy
why that one
why would you try that one no
no
no no no no
this is where in horror movies the
person would come out
but i'm not about that
i'm never gonna come out
this is what i've decided
this is where i live
and i have no desire to ever come out of
here
get used to the inside of this stall
because that's all we're ever gonna see
okay fine
i'll go
i'll go
[Music]
okay i'm guessing i need to go through
the door that he went through which i
hate but here we go
here we go
any particular reason why
the bunny has a sickle oh this is
definitely the hallway where the
terminator comes around
broken vending machine
a vending machine oh this is so not good
this is so very ungood
okay this is
bad keypad i don't have the code
[Music]
i'll take the flashlight i'll take the
flashlight
[Music]
i was looking at the tv not the door i
didn't think that there was a door there
i didn't even know there was a door
there also why did that room sound like
that why is anything like this
i don't know where i'm going
i don't know how to turn on my
flashlight that i just got
oh of course
right
ah perfect
oh
no
how did i unlock it
did i have a lock key a key did i have
the key lock
oh
interesting
okay
you know what's weird is that that sound
of like
the loading
or the scanning of the disc
on the playstation is
iconic because i did have a friend that
had a playstation and i distinctly
remember that
sound oh no
yellow jump in it
it's empty sure is buddy
it sure is pal
what about this one
it's empty of course it is why wouldn't
it be empty
why would it not be empty
okay of course it's empty
or is it
i can't reach it well [ __ ]
well okay then
guess i'll be on my way
how do i get out of here
and also where did the hell did the the
the
did the dude go
i'm gonna go back in here now that i've
got the flashlight equipped and maybe
i'll be able to see something
i doubt it though somehow i doubt it
again why is this room so noisy
again there's the tv
no nothing okay just through the door
then
no reason to be in there
there's one more thing that i need to
check in there
here what's back here some type of
equipment
shelf full of junk
empty shelf okay
nothing
oh
a screwdriver
oh perfect that was hard to find
okay well
didn't know that was there
that's okay because now i should be able
to get the thing out of the drain and
then be able to go on my way and get out
of this room of hell so into the
bathroom it's great love that
love that for me
something i can't reach
it aha
perfect easy
it's a key
okay
so what was locked
maybe the bathroom in the first place
what about one of these i can't wait
you can't use this here
what do you mean
what do you mean
well then where do i use it there's only
the other place with a keypad where
where could i possibly use it no no what
does it say it says 1024
oh oh i get it oh
[Laughter]
one oh wait no that's not gonna work
oh well that's not gonna work okay 1024
what could that mean
1024
maybe there was like a locker here in
this room was this what you would call
locker room is this what you might refer
to as a locker room with lockers in it
and if it were then mayhaps one of them
has a number
this one looks funny
one of these has to have a number
need to find something to use this on
yes i know
okay well i'm at a complete loss because
if i if this isn't to a locker then what
is this too what the hell is this too
like at one of the bathroom stalls is
the bathroom stall locked
i can't be stuck this early
[Music]
hey this is locker1024
wow
i was right there five five three four
wow i was right there i knew that i
tried i knew that one was
something
oh i tried to do oh
i tried that i tried it you all saw i
tried it
i tried it lexington
you believe me don't you
good
very good five five three four
yes
five five three four
wow good for me
okay where am i going now
what would you have of me
what would you have of me oh a break
room oh well this is nice
all right
hello
[Music]
you've got to help me
the eastern
[Music]
the easter bunny has gone crazy
[Music]
hold on there's a phone in here
let me go check it out and you wait here
all right sounds good
[Music]
i'll take care of him
you'll be safe here
unlock the door
all right bye
take care
well he's dead so sad
look out the window yeah of course
maybe i should find a place to hide
oh
oh oh
[Music]
there's a bad place to hide
oh it's a bad place to hide
oh it's a bad place died
i should have picked a better place
oh bye
hey
hey wait a minute
hey
how'd you get up on the desk
god that was just that was just the
prologue that was just the prologue
murder house well i haven't even gotten
to the house yet so i can't even be
murdered
dan weisenberger
kelsey pocket devonte johnson well sarah
noah i
look forward to playing more of this
game because murder house seems like a
house i would love to be murdered in
janitor jack
i would love to be murdered in murder
house
[Music]
yeah all right okay
you've indulged yourself
we gotta get to the murder
and here we are in present day if you
thought that was the end of the game you
got done goofed you're fooled and you
are a fool what the hell is happening
here
oh what's on my roof hmm strange
looks like we're here
ew
this place
i can't believe i went from the news
desk to this i can't believe it either
dana you're lucky you have this after
the incident with the poodle
that could have happened to anyone good
good let's get started we don't have all
day
all right let's get started
interesting
it's always great when a news van rolls
up
worked well for resident evil 7.
[Music]
i gave him 50 bucks to let
where the him is he
hey enter
your name again
emma
yeah emma make yourself useful and find
us a way in
okay i love this guy
definitely not a sleaze ball it's
literally the worst day to start this
internship and i pulled the tendon at
track practice and i don't think i can
run very long
ah the best justification for a limited
run of course of course
my tendon yeah
my tendon
all right that's all for this episode of
murder house if you want to see more of
this let me know down in the comments
below
i look forward to hearing what you think
of this game
much more horror to be seen
just beyond
anyway thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]